Global death told the Chinese
coronavirus currently sits at almost
5,000 people that's the official number
in Iran officials haven't even confirmed
a total of 500 deaths that's what
they're claiming and yet satellite image
suggests authorities are evacuating
massive trenches to hold the bodies of
victims so the lesson there and you knew
this governments lie but they're not the
only people who lie as the death toll
rises it's important to never forget how
we got here this pandemic came out of
China and it came out of China for a
reason that's a country with poor health
practices it's a country where
government officials deliberately
covered up the early stages of the virus
when it could have been stopped before
it spread out of control
in fact the outbreak may have begun not
in a public meet market but in a poorly
run Chinese laboratories now that's not
our theory anyone who raises that theory
on American television attacks is a
conspiracy monger but this is a theory
from a now censored Chinese paper a
draft paper posted in mid-february
scientists at the South China University
of Technology suggested the virus
outbreak chrono virus outbreak began at
the Wuhan Center for Disease Control
where an animal may have infected a
researcher who then spread the disease
outside the facility the paper is
explicit about this we're going to quote
it
the killer coronavirus probably
originated from a laboratory in Wuhan
end quote now we have no idea if that's
actually true but again those were
Chinese researchers making an
evidenced-based
argument about the origin of this virus
that paper has since been taken down no
explanation has been offered for that
that you can guess instead China the
same country that controls 96% of
antibiotics we use in this nation the
same country that is warning hit cutoff
drug exports to the US to kill Americans
is now trying to hide the reality of
where coronavirus came from in fact
they're doing worse than that the
Communist Party of China is trying to
blame the virus on America lesion jao
was a spokesman for China's foreign
ministry a week ago show attacked anyone
who dared to link the virus to China
certain media say this Crona virus is a
China virus this is
extremely irresponsible and we firmly
oppose that too we are still tracing the
origin of the virus and there is no
conclusion yet that was last week Joe
has evolved since then today on Twitter
he accused America of creating the virus
quote when did patient zero begin in
u.s. how many people are infected were
the names of the hospitals it might be
US Army that brought the epidemic to
Wuhan be transparent make public your
data US owes us an explanation
exclamation point keep in mind these are
the people the Chinese leadership that
our media class has allied with has
sucked up to four years has made every
excuse for endlessly even when China
blamed the United States for a plague
they unleashed even when the Chinese
government threatened to murder our
citizens by cutting off drugs our media
continued to take their side watch this
the president referred to the corona
virus as a quote foreign virus and I
think it's going to smack it's going to
come across to a lot of Americans as
smacking of xenophobia that was cNN's
Jim Acosta a poisonous [ __ ] amazingly
though it was just two months ago and we
keep track that Acosta was sending
tweets himself about the quote Wuhan
coronavirus he hadn't yet received his
orders from jeff zucker who receives his
from china so that was okay but now the
word is out must protect china at all
costs even presidential candidates are
playing along watch this downplaying it
feet overly dismissive or spreading
misinformation is only gonna hurt us and
further advantage the spread of the
disease but neither should we panic or
fall back on xenophobia labeling copa 19
a foreign virus does not displace
accountability for the misjudgments that
have been taken thus far by the trump
administration so it's our fault just to
be clear describing a virus from Wuhan
as the Wuhan virus is not xenophobia its
accuracy and anyone who says other
wise is lying and probably for a reason
in any crisis our government's chief
obligation is to the lives of our
citizens it's not to other countries
it's not to the GDP it's certainly not
to the Communist Party of China but for
our ruling class the highest priority of
all is now and always woke 'no statin
approval from Beijing tells you
everything about them